So let's see one way to do it, together.
To get the value of the left_child, I'll just call eval_exp recursively.
To get the value of the right_child, I'll do the same--
but for the right-hand side of the Abstract Syntax Tree.
If the operator is (+), I'll just add them together--
returning the sum of the left_value and the right_value.
Otherwise, if the operator is (-),
I'll just subtract them--return the left_value minus the right_value.
To some of you, this may seem a little weird.
I'm defining (+) in terms of (+) in Python.
That is, in order to explain how JavaScript works,
I'm saying well, JavaScript asked you to do some Addition--
why don't you just do it in Python?
But remember that an interpreter is really like
a translator--so it should not be surprising.
If you were teaching someone how to speak French
and they ask you what does a French word mean--
what's the French word for "big" or how do I interpret the French word "grande"--
you might tell them: oh, it's just like the word "big"
in the language that we speak.
And this is that notion of their universal underlying concepts
but we just have slightly different syntax for them.
In this particular case, it looks a little weird
because the JavaScript and the Python syntax for (+)
are exactly the same.
But you'll see slight differences later.
Remember that, for example, in function declarations,
JavaScript and Python do actually look different.
So it should look very similar now
because the translation is very direct.
This is like Romance languages
that share common Latin roots.